in the 550 Plus pages of this book there
is a lot more detail than we were
expecting from Prince Harry as he tells
his story within this Memoir a lot of
headlines have already been made but
there are some key elements that
certainly stand out as he retells this
story of growing up and living within
the Limelight that he he had and the
focus of the the press's uh attention
look one of the things that he talks
about a lot here is the impact that his
mother's death had on him and growing up
it is a raw level of emotion that he
talks about having to process 10 years
on from his mother's death there is one
incident that particularly stands out he
talks about how he was in Paris to watch
a rugby match when he asked the driver
that he was with to drive him through
the same tunnel that his mother was at
the time when she died and this is what
he says in the book I told him the
tunnel was called Ponte Alma yes yes he
knew it I told him I wanted to go
through it do you want to go through the
tunnel at 105 kilometers per hour to be
precise it was a terrible idea that was
the night all doubts were dispelled
she's dead I thought my God she's really
gone forever and he goes on to talk
about the PTSD that he's experienced
over the years and how he's actually
ended up needing therapy to actually
process everything that every emotion
that he went through another thing that
really has made headlines uh has been uh
he uh his brother and his take on the
fact that his father wanted to remarry
now he said he wanted his father to be
happy but they both said that they
really didn't want their dad to remarry
and he says in the book just as I was
embarking on my new love affair he just
met a new girlfriend my father announced
that he was getting married despite
Willie and I asking him not to my father
kept going despite the bitterness and
sadness we felt at closing another group
in our mother's story we understood that
it was irrelevant
also one element that has been making a
lot of headlines has been the fractious
relationship that has now grown up
between him and his brother William
he talks in one incident of a physical
altercation that happens between him and
his brother it's after he's married his
wife Megan William comes over to his
house and says that he's confronting him
about his wife saying that she's
abrasive and rude to people that work at
the palace and this is what happens next
he says everything happened so fast
really really fast he grabbed me by the
collar of my shirt ripping my necklace
and he knocked me to the floor I fell on
top of the dog's bowl which cracked
under my back the pieces of it cutting
into me I lay on the ground for a few
seconds dazed then got up and told him
to leave
that isn't the only uh story that we
have seen within the book that has also
been making headlines look let's take
you through uh one certainly that has uh
stood out today uh with regards to Harry
and his two tours that he had fighting
in Afghanistan a lot of people
questioning how wise it was for him to
talk about the number of people that he
ended up killing while he was out
fighting in Afghanistan this is what he
says on that so my number 25 it was not
something that filled me with
satisfaction but I was not ashamed
either naturally I would have preferred
not to have that figure on my military
resume or in my head but I would also
have preferred to live in a world
without the Taliban a world without war
and a lot of people are Smalling a lot
of military experts have been
questioning really just how good taste
it it is really to put a a precise
number on the number of people that he
has ended up killing the number of
Taliban fighters and perhaps the worst
learning that dehumanizes really those
people that he ended up killing look as
well as this the other thing that a lot
of people have been talking about in the
last 24 hours Harry's admission of using
drugs
there's uh several anecdotes within the
book this is one where he taught in a
fairly sort of childish immature way
really if you like about going around to
the friend star Courtney Cox's house
being excited because he was a big
friend star opening uh her fridge and he
says I caught a glimpse of a huge box of
magic mushroom chocolates in the shape
of a black if black chocolate diamonds
my friend and I grabbed a few and
gobbled them up and washed them down
with tequila so at times he certainly
does have a tone of sounding quite
immature the one that really has stood
out though the drug reference to a lot
of people is when he is a teenager at 17
talking about taking cocaine after he
went hunting with a group of friends of
course I had been taking cocaine at the
time it did make me feel different I was
a 17 year old willing to try almost
anything and he talks about basically
wanting to be outside of his own head
and not wanting to to or wanting to have
some escapism if you like from his
everyday life look there's a lot of
grand Revelations there is also a huge
amount of just over sharing in this book
as well did the world really need to
know details like this how Harry lost
his virginity I'd recently lost my
virginity virginity a humiliating
episode with an older lady who loved
horses very much and treated me like a
young stallion one of my mistakes was
letting it happen in a field just behind
a busy Pub
it's moments like this where you have to
say it does somewhat detract from from
the serious points that he wants to make
in the book certainly he he hasn't held
back in this he's been very open in
Sharing what he feels is his truth
putting his side of uh his life story
out there
really though the question is how well
this will be received and how damaging
perhaps this will be for his reputation
given the level of over sharing